les adieux était émouvant sur le plateau
de district 31 car après six ans de
travail intense techniciens et comédiens
ont développé une complicité quasi
fusionnelle c'est du bon
c'est dur je me fais avoir c'est ça qui
me rendent le plus mais il est cher j'en
parle plus je deviens déjà un peu émotif
f-15 nadine depuis ce premier épisode
diffusé en septembre 2016 gistré
contient est devenu il quotidienne culte
au québec quatre soirs par semaine la
série policière était au rendez vous
pour les téléspectateurs et un marathon
pour les acteurs on sort de l'eau grandi
comme tu dis je pas le matin je changer
physiquement aussi beaucoup j'étais dans
des zones auxquelles je n'ai pas
l'habitude d'aller parce que bon j'ai
été formé en comédie mais là j'ai été
happé par le drame dans cette
quotidienne d'eau puis jt jeudi jusqu'à
date cependant le rôle de ma vie près de
3000 comédien et six mille figurants ont
travaillé dans le district 31 le podium
et fabienne larouche ont été de réelles
complice dans cette aventure c'est sûr
que c'était
une grande aventure dans nos vies c'est
de michel et moi de producteurs avec
l'udc
les acteurs et ses six années de grand
plaisir
toujours dans les conditions faciles la
pandémie et intense qui se passe
lorsque j'ai un petit coup de base et je
me suis dit qu'on allait aussi je lis
fait c'est joli des sinistres d'un
papier 31 juillet on entre ici la
dernière saison de district entier se
termine au sommet avec un auditoire
moyen de près deux millions huit cent
mille téléspectateurs et 50% de parts de
marché il ya un sentiment du devoir
accompli la pyramide du deuil est rendu
hier au moment où je suis juste sereine
j'ai besoin de vie n'est pas finie je
suis triste que ça se termine mais je
content que ça se termine aussi un sens
kg j j'ai bien je pense avoir bien fait
ce
en cette dernière journée de tournage le
commandant fiasson nous rassure la
grande finale sera inoubliable des lames
du sein et des g le dire et
comme dans toutes les finales de
district et
après cette photo de famille le 700 20e
et dernier épisode de district en t1
sera diffusé le 21 avril sur i télé il y
aura le même soir deux émissions
spéciales et une autre en coulisses le
24 avril ici louis fait depuis mai
radio-canada vaut rien